yannick and gawkway wants out of
jacksonville he's subject to the
franchise tag he's made it clear that
he's ready for a new start the jaguars
are making it clear that they're not
going to let him go unless they get a
significant package espn reports that
the jaguars are beginning their talks on
nagaway looking for a first round pick
and more now last year frank clark
netted for the seahawks a first round
pick in 2019 a second round pick in 2020
d4 got for the chiefs only a second
round pick in 2020 so maybe in gawkway
somewhere in between but look here's the
reality
whoever trades foreign is acquiring the
immediate obligation to sign him to a
massive long-term deal and that
necessarily is going to impact the
willingness to give the jaguars a major
package peter it's a sliding scale the
more you give the team the less you give
the player the more you give the player
the less you give the team so it's not
going to be an easy deal to get done but
i think at some point the jaguars just
have to call the ball and move on from
in gawkway and i think they want to they
just have to be coy about it and they
have to act like they're digging in
their feet in order to get the best
possible deal
i think if i were the jaguars a
realistic package to me
is a low one and a four
um
something like that
uh or maybe two two twos two two with
the two this year
being say in the first ten picks of the
round so and i know they'll say oh my
god we'll never do that well then you're
gonna have a very unhappy player on a
team that
probably everybody in that organization
is fighting for its job
uh and you'll have also a player who
will cost you a jillion dollars in 2021
if you have to franchise them for a
second time so
i i think they're going to be forced to
take the best deal they can in fact tony
buselli who does jaguars on the radio
said yesterday uh on the jaguars
flagship station that he thinks that
he'll it was he was very sure that he'll
be gone uh this offseason i shouldn't
say very sure but he just thought he
would be gone this offseason my feeling
is mike jaguars need to get realistic
and cut out the last bit
of real unhappy player
from their 2019 team
uh biselli by the way one of the covid19
victims who has recovered he shared some
comments yesterday about what a scary
experience that was we have the story at
profootballtalk.com
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports